hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
going to explain a 2022 psychological
thriller movie called orphan first kill
in Estonia 2007 a young woman named Anna
arrives at The sarn Institute an Estonia
mental hospital
it's her first day working as an art
therapy instructor and she seems uneasy
when she enters the building for the
first time later she is welcomed by the
head of the Institute Dr Novotny who
gives her a brief explanation about the
security procedure suddenly the
situation becomes tense and the place
goes into lockdown when a doctor informs
them that their most dangerous patient
has escaped from her room for her safety
Dr Novotny locks Anna inside a dark room
until everything is secured there Anna
encounters a young girl who introduces
herself as Lena klamer despite her
body's size and baby face Anna becomes
very terrified as she realizes that Lena
is the patient the doctors are looking
for before Lena can attack Anna with her
pencil the doctors break into the room
and take the patient back into custody
Anna is shocked after knowing that the
most violent patient in the mental
institute is actually a child but Dr
Novotny later explains that Lena who is
actually a 31 years old grown woman
suffers a Glam disorder causing her body
to stop growing at a certain age he
continues that two years ago Lena used
her body advantage to get adopted into a
happy family at some point she attempted
to seduce the father of the family but
failed because of that she murdered the
whole family and was sent to the sarn
Institute lastly the doctor tells Anna
that Lena has scars around her neck and
wrists because of being restrained
that night a hospital attendant named
Dimitri comes across Lena's cell to
deliver a package she notices that
Dimitri has a feeling towards her so she
convinces him to come into the cell Lina
attempts to tease him until she catches
him off guard then she ruthlessly
smashes his head against the wall
afterwards she steals his ID card and
begins to make her way out just before
she reaches the exit door a security
guard confronts her Lena orders another
patient to attack the guard and
subsequently gives her a candy as a
reward outside the building Anna sees
Lena escaping and immediately returns to
the hospital
feeling horrified she quits the job on
the first day Anna returns home and
somehow her car trunk suddenly opens but
she finds no one there as she gets into
the house Lena greets him and hits him
in the head Lena goes upstairs and uses
Anna's computer to go through a missing
child database until she finds Esther a
missing girl who Lena closely resembles
as she makes her way out she figures out
that Anna is still alive thus she ends
her life in the most miserable way not
long after she is found by the local
officer in the middle of the snow using
the information she got earlier she
admits that her name is Esther and her
parents are in America meanwhile in a
coastal town called Darion trica and
Alan are attending a fencing competition
to support their Elder son Gunner turns
out that they are Esther's parents and
the couple especially the husband are
still in grief since their daughter's
disappearance suddenly Donna a detective
who has been working on Esther's case
meets the couple to tell them that their
daughter has been found trica
immediately flies to Russia to pick up
her daughter who turns out to be Lena
the fake Esther trica is so excited with
the return of her daughter and flies
back to the U.S the next day on their
way trika shows Lena a photograph of her
grandmother Lena answers that she can't
wait to see her again but turns out that
she had passed away the mother becomes a
little bit suspicious and Lena
immediately goes to the restroom to calm
herself down long story short they
arrive and the family finally reunites
again
however Gunner seems unhappy with the
fact that her sister has come back to
the family
Lena sees her new house for the first
time trying to adapt with the new
environment the next day the fake Esther
is brought to Dr Seeger who performs
some psychological tests on her however
Lena suddenly stands up and awkwardly
talks to the parrot and calls it Sydney
which grows suspicion on the doctor
because it is not the same bird while
waiting outside the room Lena
deliberately spills a drink to the
assistant and then eavesdrops on the
conversation between trica and Dr Seeger
the doctor tells the mother that there
are some behavioral changes Lena then
makes a scene accusing a boy of ripping
her dress on their way Lena spots done
and taking pictures of them from a
distance at home Alan takes Lena to his
Art Studio where he shows her some of
his masterpieces she admits that she is
interested in arts and requests to draw
a portrait of Alan which he agrees to
moments later Alan is Amazed by the
result and intends to teach her more
about painting that evening trica sneaks
into Lena's room and attempts to read
her Bible but the fake Esther
immediately runs towards her and grabs
the book after The Mother leaves she
finds Esther's diary
she learns about Esther's personality
and tries to mimic her during the family
dinner Donnan shows up to make sure that
everything is all right Lena who feels
uneasy with his presence hides in the
kitchen while overhearing the
conversation afraid that her real
identity will be exposed she steals
jewelry and plans to run away from the
house however she eventually decides to
stay longer as she wants to get closer
to Alan few days later when the couple
is about to get intimate Lena suddenly
walks across the room and gets jealous
of them she then rips Trish's dress for
her gala still that night Alan and
Trisha attended Gala for Trisha's work
so Gunner invites his friends over for a
party meanwhile Donna stops by the house
telling Gunner that he wants to use the
bathroom instead he sneaks into Lena's
room to collect some samples Lena
observes him from a distance and decides
to follow him home Alan and Trisha come
back home earlier than expected Trisha
goes to Lena's room and reads his Bible
diary finding out that the book belongs
to the sarn Institute as well as Donna's
home address
Donna learns that Lena's fingerprint
does not match Esther's fingerprint but
before he can reveal the fact of the
parents he is stabbed multiple times by
Lena surprisingly Tricia appears out of
nowhere and shoots the detective to
death
shortly after Lena reveals her true
identity to Trisha who is not impressed
at all because she is known about her
whole ruse all along turns out that the
real Esther was accidentally killed by
Gunner and Trisha helped her son to
cover it up by dumping her body down to
a bunker she tells Lena that the only
reason she keeps going along with Lena's
trick is because of Alan the women
eventually throw Donna's corpse into the
same bunker send an email to a superior
and subsequently agree to work together
until a mutually beneficial Arrangement
is met when they return home Trisha and
Lena act like nothing's happened still
that night Trisha tells Gunner the truth
who disagrees to live longer with Lena
the following day Trisha guides Esther
on how to act like the real Esther by
telling her Esther's old memories they
returned to Dr Seeger's place where she
manages to convince the doctor with her
stories back at the house Gunner
confronts Lena in her room making it
clear that he owns her only to get
slapped twice in the face
before family dinner Trisha pours a
large dose of her sleeping pills and
Lena's food Lena gets suspicious and
decides to take it to her room instead
of eating the mac and cheese she gives
it to the rat afterwards Alan invites
her to join him working while showing
her the art of black light effect
painting When Alan is away Trisha
appears and tells Lena to stay away from
her husband because he will never be
hers before going to sleep Lena notices
that the rat has died due to overdose
and eventually realizes that Trisha is
up to something in the morning Lena
surprisingly prepares breakfast for the
family
she also gives her mother a special
smoothie with a dead rat inside it the
family goes to the train station to
accompany Allen before he departs to
work at some point Lena attempts to push
Trisha and Gunner onto the railways but
fails as soon as Allen enters the train
Trisha tells Lena that it's her time to
finish her off
however Lena manages to break free and
sprays Gunner with pepper sprays she
then steals Trish's car and drives away
in the middle of the road she is stopped
by police and escorted back home
in the house Gunner and Trisha can't
take it anymore and plan to eliminate
her they confront Lena in her room where
Gunner grabs her and the mother attempts
to cut her off unfortunately Lena
manages to break free but is chased by
Gunner he accidentally pushes her off
the stairs thinking that she's dead
already meanwhile Allen informs his wife
that he'll come home early which makes
the situation worse for them shortly
after Lena goes missing and Gunner is
told to finish her off he chases her
alone to Alan's Studio where she shoots
him with a crossbow then stabbing him
ruthlessly to death
Trisha sees the crime and becomes very
enraged she chases Lena all over the
house wreaking havoc on the kitchen the
fight sets the house on fire but Trisha
ignores it and keeps chasing the
psychopath to the roof as the women
fight on the roof Allen arrives at the
house and follows them to the rooftop
Allen is forced to make a hard decision
and he eventually decides to save Lena
from falling in time sacrificing her own
wife who falls and smashes her head on
the pavement not long after Lena's fake
teeth fall out which makes Alan freak
out Lena eventually pushes him off the
roof killing him as well a few moments
later as the house is fully burned Lena
walks out of the house and fools the
authorities by pretending to be Esther
sometimes later Lena is brought to Dr
Seeger who decides to search for new
foster parents for her
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching